[Music]
welcome back to off the record where we
talk about
whatever we want [ __ ] life
oh is that [ __ ] life that's the life
that i live
i live like a [ __ ] in what way what do
you mean not even gender-specific
i'm just coward i'm just cowardly that
could be a cool t-shirt
huh what comes with that lifestyle yeah
what are some decisions like you pull
out of the driveway and then what
happens
oh for once you get on the freeway what
do you see you
live by uh what's the
how do they say it it's like no like
like how they go like the path of
least resistance yes there's no shame in
trying to survive
it's underrated actually with the least
amount of work possible
so you know people they pride themselves
in hard work i say
you stupid that sounds smart yeah
so why go to war and become a hero
when you die there's no live heroes
would you consider that
gamifying i want to be the guy that
survives the war
to tell the story about how cool it was
and then honorable
heroes no but you survived it because
you didn't even fight in it
so nobody who the narrator in the movies
nobody who ever survived a war
is a hero jojo's a coward
went on record by saying that too i'm
like the guy that was like
probably working in the medic stuff and
then like when
all the brave soldiers came in i hear
their stories while i manage them
and i'm like damn that's crazy thanks
for going out there for me bro
yeah or you're the cook or the cook
thunder the quarter mask
the guy with the hook hands david's the
cook david's gonna be out there
being a super tough cook correct me if
i'm wrong i feel like medics are heroes
yeah yeah they're we're heroes oh
because they're superheroes they're
saving people all the time not if they
survived though that's what
that's what joe's trying to talk about
put on the last band-aid and go
i want to be the medic at the tent bro i
don't even want to be the front line
medic that goes in
and [ __ ] covers the [ __ ] body with
their body and then they drag them back
and
after dragging their homies back they
get shot oh you ain't trying to be like
hacksaw ridge no no
no no for me i'm the guy in the
ambulance like
that'll go pick them up and then i'll
drive back you know
yeah i was thinking about um that when i
was watching you know that new
movie edge of tomorrow or some [ __ ] with
tom cruise
yeah yeah new yeah yeah emily it's a
great movie that's an awesome movie i'm
moving
rocks i gotta see it it's [ __ ]
awesome it's like some spaceships
in like 10 years it's so it's so good
yeah it's like
what is it not the butterfly effect but
the groundhog day where the it's it
repeats over yeah yeah yeah yeah
spoiler alert it's kind of a spoiler
okay yeah but then i was thinking about
the world war ii right the the guys that
are
on the ship and on the plane like you
were there at d-day
yeah but you're dropping fools off so
like who are the real heroes the guys
that get dropped off and they just run
they don't even get to shoot one shot
and they get shot or whatever
you know so the guys who are dropping
them off those are the real heroes i see
what you're saying
as long as they die no no if they die
they're really gross but if they
because i want to be the guy on the
plane that's like [ __ ] i'm a part of
this too
but then as soon as i drop them off i
can go back and pick up more people yeah
you're
banking already the shuttle you're the
shuttle i'm the shuttle guy
that takes people from like america to
like the camp ah
yeah yeah yeah yeah i'll be the show he
wants to be he's flying
and then he's like and he sees like the
[ __ ] tourette aim at him he goes i'm
gonna drop you off right here
you ain't gonna right now you gotta get
him right now get out right now jump
right
dropping you guys here yeah i'm the guy
that takes him to america to england
we are not near the lz repeat we are not
near the lz anyway
get the [ __ ] out we are landing in the
middle of the ocean for some reason
we're getting new orders you have to get
dropped off walk out of my plane [ __ ]
as far as it's live right i'm going to
shoot you myself go upside down until
you guys leave my plane i'm going upside
down
get out of my [ __ ] plane right now i
thought you had to swim in the marines
right so
swim i don't know well
bart you you're you're kind of like my
role right in the military you were the
supply
guy i imagine that's what supply guys do
they
they give snacks to the soldiers right
you deliver snacks right yeah it's not
not my
my unit kind of sucks huh so is bart a
hero or not no he survived i survived i
mean you're not a hero because he didn't
cause he's surprised oh so i'm not a
hero but he had a very important job
without those snipers bart
is alive to tell the story of his
comrades yeah that's true because he
didn't even go to war
everyone went to afghanistan and he's
like these are some brave men
he's just like a walking diary
can you send me can you email me these
cool stories so i could tell them on jk
newsletter
the guy at the end of the movie with the
photo from your uh
friend that died and you deliver it to
his wife oh
yeah you're that guy he's the guy that
volunteered
to go for me yeah so i get to have the
life now
and then you're a dick so you just like
marry the wife later on because like the
hero
him and geo met yeah that's true yeah
and then they come out of the dust
because they were actually just a
prisoner and they weren't really dead
and then they're like what do we do now
i'm like what are you doing here ben
affleck
yeah get the [ __ ] out of here oh yeah
passed away
and they have a moment but then they
know it's over yeah
oh man what's gonna happen then what
would you guys do if you were in the
military what would you do
oh i'd do what what my brothers did i'd
serve in the chair force and
chair forces worry about getting
frostbite from all the ac
[Laughter]
that's the basically you would be you
would be the the
the guy on the computer yeah i'm telling
me to where to
drop off the [ __ ] soldiers my wrists
hurt really bad
i'm a radar man yeah also a very
important job though very important job
important
i don't know enough about the military
to know what i would i'd be water supply
bro and uh bring water to the soldiers
purify the water that's it you purified
the water
instructor dude no i'm not i'm not that
good at swimming bro like let's be real
i'd probably be like uh like the captain
america before he was an actual hero
just like go around like perform and
just hopefully lift the spirits
oh uso show dude
you know like that's where they have
shield outfits that's actually honestly
one of the best jobs see so when i was
when i joined the military
so they have these things called billets
right which are like positions in the
military
and depending on their needs they have
different incentives for certain things
at the time that i joined uh they needed
trombone players
in the marine corps band that's
literally and if you were to join
at that time it's an automatic promotion
to e6 which is like a
usually takes people at least eight
years to get to this job
so you start at that salary the thing is
though to play the trombone you still
have to go to boot camp and like mct
which is like still hard as [ __ ] but
once you're done with it
you get to just immediately jump eight
steps in your
trombone plane and you never have to do
anything hard after so what does a
trombone player do in the military you
go to all these camps and
trombone it is the white house you play
at the white house
or you play at the rose bowl like like
those kind of things
you're kind of like embassy events
you're like an entertainer in the
military that's what i'm saying
like you know how like in korea uh
everybody all the men have to go to the
military by like a certain time
like two years ago right so there's a
lot of like really really um
high level of famous b boys that are in
korea that have to get drafted and go to
the military anyway
and then after they're a b-boy yeah they
might be like world champion
yeah what about bts do you think bts
they they probably have to do it as well
realistically everybody has to he served
in world war ii and you know how like
they used to have the drummer guys like
in the revolutionary war and [ __ ] yeah
they had elvis doing blue suede shoes
like in the front
stupid no he
that's why they want dude hey dude
that's intimidating as [ __ ] that's why
they won
his guitar was a gun you hear those
footsteps and then you hear you start to
hear him like
you're like oh [ __ ] he's here karate you
know
[Laughter]
sometimes like it's like a fog and it's
like in the middle of the night
and then these german soldiers are like
i'm also
[Laughter]
everybody [ __ ] you just got shot by
elvis dude
me too that's how we won the
war dude he's he won the holocaust yeah
so that's what we're doing elvis won the
holidays he won the holocaust that's a
quote
yeah great quote he freed it
for his people korean b-boys that you
know they're all going into the military
now
um everybody always has to go or they
flee the country and then like move
forever it's like a two-year theme right
at least two years or something like
that but then even when they go some of
the b boys they'll let go and
uh they'll be in that performance unit
and they'll like travel to like
different places and perform that's like
a sick ass job
wow because like everybody knows who
they are already but like everybody also
knows a situation where you
all have to go in is it based off luck
like if you're lucky enough to get put
in that type of unit or i don't know
like but all i know all i heard rumor
has it i don't know if i'm allowed to
talk about this
um this is one people his name's hong 10
he was like he's like one of the best b
was in the world korean dude a dope name
yeah hong kong one red bull bc one two
times
and the second time was at the 10 year
anniversary of all stars all returning
champions went to korea for this
championship
but i believe was when he was in the
actively serving in the military but he
like snuck out to go win the
championship
and then he won it and then went back
wow i'm a b-boy though it sounds like
[ __ ] made [ __ ]
it's like hey i'm the number one b-boy
it's like that sounds like [ __ ] boy
though
get steve out of here dude sorry dude
eric
my recruiter he played for la galaxy as
a pro soccer player
oh [ __ ] and he's also on the marine
corps soccer team and so he had all
kinds of
soccer teams what does the marine corps
soccer team do
there's like yeah it's football there's
like a boxing the wrestling team does
the marine corps soccer team go like
[ __ ] play the like air force soccer
team
like that's pretty much all they play so
there's only four teams i think so
do they do other things yeah do they do
other things or do they just rep
their division practice and then they
play and then i think they do
all pr type [ __ ] damn wow i didn't know
they had sports teams do they battle the
i bet you the coast guards get
[ __ ] up by everybody oh yeah you know
they do they got like seven people on
their team
coast guard reserve guys are getting
wrecked
[Laughter]
yeah but my recruiter had like all kinds
of cool privileges where he could like
go and fly to wherever usually you
always have to be like on your
assignment but you can go and fly
and play pro soccer and come back and do
it the hell are people trying to go into
like the the military for recreational
stuff i don't think so because it's not
a known thing
you know what i mean like i didn't know
any others like when you see like
billboards and [ __ ] it's usually some
fool like coming out of the water with
[ __ ] camo paint
it's not the guy with the trombone like
play for the president
yeah it's like call of duty fifa yeah
yeah maybe if they did that more like
they have interpreters
like almost every job you can think of
in the civilian sector
including [ __ ] cable repairman you
probably have it
because the bases are pretty much cities
wow so everything you can think of
you could probably find like the the
military counterpart to it
dude i was this close of joining the
military in high school but i became a
communist and an anarchist and
yeah i became very woke before woke
became a thing
so um that's very hipster i started
realizing that
mercenary is much better of a career
choice
than a than a soldier because what i
found out
is that a lot of career soldiers if
they're not in the u.s
military and then making like half a
million dollars being like an officer
at a high rank then uh they end up
like if they're infantry guys they
become mercenaries yeah
yeah and then how do you become a
mercenary if you don't go through
any military training it's really hard
yeah i would imagine almost
everyone is military trained yeah they
have to yeah but but you can go to
other military training to become a
mercenary right and back then
so like i knew about al qaeda before 9
11
because that's how people will get
military training
and experience is through constructs
conscripting to these different
terrorist organizations
and then you go through their boot camp
and you you go whatever and then you
you become a soldier a fortune for like
a small country
or like a warlord or whatever and then
you just practice
there and then you build up your resume
so it's like some real
like double-oh-seven like lord of war
[ __ ] dude
have you guys seen that video in south
africa of those two guys
driving an awesome truck yes and they're
insane
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah and the guys are
just like
just driving like one cat who's driving
he's just like yeah whatever [ __ ] these
[ __ ] and then the guy next to him is
like oh what the [ __ ]
man yeah he's like the audience the
audience is like what the [ __ ] going
on he's
he's like representing us yeah dude that
guy's eyes are just like really big but
he's still very calm like he's still
like
holy [ __ ] that's like our buddy don dude
yeah that's gonna be his first special
operations assignment because you know
it's you're not going there a big
infantry you're trying to leave a small
footprint
so you have a small group of guys
jumping out of a plane and you sneak in
the night the cover of the night and
they get into his first fire
fight and you can't really like phone
[ __ ] in because you're not even supposed
to be there in the first place you
have to take care of it and his boss
bullets are flying down range and he's
just [ __ ] smoking a cigarette he's
pretty much telling don to stop being a
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah and just wait for
them to run up
see and that's why don couldn't make
delta i'm telling you man
that's such too much of a [ __ ] dude
[ __ ] doesn't know what to do with
those right
my bullets were flying and he was just
smoking a cigarette and waiting that
sounds like an anime
yeah he was just like just chill out
that's why
don is my man crush bro that dude is a
[ __ ] hero he is a handsome warrior i
know dude too beautiful to be fighting
in war
yeah i felt like that similarly when i
was playing paintball i was like this is
[ __ ] crazy
i was like wow uh people are trying to
get me hey but also like that's kind of
real though cause you imagine your head
while you're going with that moment
you're like imagine if these were real
[ __ ] bullets yeah
i would cower and sit down and cry like
that it's colorful i'm waiting for all
this yellow paint to run out
that's it with some pink ones that's the
downside every time i get shot in
um airsoft i go dude this is the reason
why i'm not going to last very long your
war
dude for real i run too much into the
opening
you know you you don't use any tactics
nope i just run in and pam
i hear a 12 year old going i hate you
you're you gotta be out i'm like [ __ ]
[ __ ] go back to liberia dude
[Laughter]
what are you doing here that's why i
think i'm way more [ __ ] made than you
because i like laser tag
laser tag yeah that [ __ ] could really
[ __ ] up your eyes if it gets up
that's way more dangerous that was a
[ __ ] made comment right there
all right you beat me i can't do this i
don't [ __ ] with my eyes
airsoft hurts you know you purposely
wear like long clothes and [ __ ] so that
like
when the bbs hit you doesn't hurt but
then sometimes you've been moving around
through your sleeves here and he goes
right there put these things in
i remember i went airsoft thing once and
that was the last time i went
and it was uh when i was like 18 and i
went with a couple of my buddies
half of them were all 12 year olds right
and you're 18. you're good too
yeah i'm 18. and then the other half was
grown men that come up
in full camo they look like they're in
the military
they open up their [ __ ] their guns are
yeah they got
flashlights yeah and they're shooting
little kids
they're [ __ ] these couches they're
just [ __ ] all these kids up and
they're always winning and they're
destroying
them in the parking lot before you get
to the park they're sure with their
ankles and [ __ ] you know what i mean
they're bullying them online afterwards
they got airsoft grenades and [ __ ]
yeah yeah they're just throwing them it
is fun shooting those kids but at the
same time
they're [ __ ] too man because they're
so small they can hide everywhere
you don't see them and then they'll just
be sniping you out
yeah just getting shot they're good too
like you'll just be like
running pop i got you it sounds like
you're narrating the vietnamese war
that's why children are so hard to stop
i don't dude if i was a billionaire if
i'm jeff bezos i'm making an airsoft
apache
[ __ ] helicopter i'm just [ __ ]
sweeping bro sweeping no joke they do
that do they really
yeah like the the events that like ryan
goes to and all these guys
it's like big events camp out for days
and you [ __ ] march miles right and
they have
it's like real warsaw they have tanks
they have
all this [ __ ] yeah dude i'm gonna build
an airsoft nuke and end the war
how many babies is that a trillion
babies
i'll split the atom with airsoft around
it
i think nobody's done that before bezos
has a great sniper eye too
oh he does yeah he does he has he has
those eyes that you know
he's seen some [ __ ] yeah yeah no one
else does yeah
has drone eyes satellite drone eyes
he has walleyes i know that's what i
call it walleyes yeah walleyes
where you're looking at somebody and
you're like oh [ __ ] can't get away from
their eyes
the mona lisa eyes yeah exactly like
it's like when you're looking it's like
you're in the haunted mansion
you're like god damn i'm actually moving
too yeah his father once told him to
keep his eyes on the prize and you never
look back
in every room
so three minutes huh we're good
all right guys let me talk about the
next three minutes
[Laughter]
wait how did it get to bezels well
because they're uh
the apache airsoft apache yeah okay we
were all military i
i don't know where it went down dude
this coffee's [ __ ] me up bro like i
mean
i came into the strongest coffee i've
ever had in my life low-key like i feel
like
you feel drunk yeah i feel like
lightheaded i love it vietnamese coffee
by this halfway point you're a different
human being especially
mr baguette so this is how you know how
strong this is this is
so [ __ ] strong that for me to dilute
it i poured this coffee
more colder i was like i'm gonna put
this in to dilute this [ __ ]
it changes my personality when i drink
this
bro i'm like seeing stars and [ __ ] dogs
like i don't know what's going on really
yeah i'm like tripping up really i'm
fine though i'm good
i'm good i'm totally fine and you're
drunk so wow what the [ __ ] is that
one time i drank all of this in during
one episode right
and by the next one i was like smiling
like this but i thought i was gonna
faint
and my heart was exploding in my chest
yeah and i was like i might have to go
to the er
but then two episodes in i was like i'm
cool
yeah this is how vietnam won the war you
hype all your soldiers up with this [ __ ]
right i kind of i kind of get it now the
nazis had meth
yeah we have cafe soda yeah did you guys
grow up on this
is this like a normal thing i wasn't
allowed to drink it because it's so
strong yeah nobody's supposed to worry
so your parents knew how strong it was
yeah they were like [ __ ]
not drinking like hell no this kid's
crazy we give her this imagined
oh yeah i would have been [ __ ] on one
if i had this as a kid
that was my favorite thing to tell my
grandpa because he would talk [ __ ] to me
and i'd be like at least i didn't lose a
[ __ ] war
[Laughter]
you dropped the ball that one which one
was he in korean he was in korean war
and in the vietnam war
oh he's just taking left and right huh i
was like bro he lost both
two [ __ ] wars yeah [ __ ]
wait but uh yeah i don't think you guys
cleaned up either
[ __ ] at that point you just gotta beat
the child right
by the way i do it at uh veterans
gatherings kills every time kills every
time memorial they love you you
are mostly memorial i love you yeah
murders
on veterans day that's the best time to
perform it good it's good
for all of our fallen shoulders uh yeah
we should have done better guys
steve's right he's absolutely maybe one
no
we could try it a little harder in the
second half guys and then it's like
okay he did that damn that one doesn't
work
tough crowd it's getting it's getting
too real in my head right now
did i do the um if you if you came back
you're not a real hero
i did do that okay i don't think you hit
your prisoner of war joke yet
oh that's right that's what it is yeah
p.o.w.s huh
weak my grandpa was a p.o.w
was he what yeah on which side uh he was
both a vietnamese soldier that helped
the americans and when the americans
pulled out
him and his group of friends were uh
taken as prisoners of
re-education camps right yes and my
grandma used to try to come and visit
him but they wouldn't let her see him
did they pop his fingernails off i have
no idea he still has them now so i don't
think so but everyone says that
he was never the same after he came back
i heard they do some
torture [ __ ] like leave you out
in the sun just in like a [ __ ]
crucifix and just
for days they do some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
yeah
that's why day one i'm just like my
name's steve green i'm in the u.s army
and yeah i'll tell you where everybody
is dude just give me chocolate sundae
[Laughter]
and we're square i don't know if that's
how it works
three scoops please extra peanuts
like you got to need that cafe suit down
you have a bunny i'm like where's my
[ __ ] diet coke guys come on
dude you should see this doc about a
north korean
american defector from the u.s military
that went into north korea oh [ __ ] and
then they basically use them as a
propaganda tool but he lived a good life
in north korea wow yeah
[Music]
you